the centers for disease control and
prevention is giving its blessing
for fully vaccinated americans to travel
just in time for easter weekend
it comes amid a wave of soaring
infections and as more states scale back
their coronavirus restrictions
101 million doses of the coronavirus
vaccine have now been administered in
this country
that means almost 58 million americans
are fully
vaccinated even though the seven day
average of new infections is
up more than 8 percent tom hanson is
here in new york with more tom good
morning
hey there michelle good morning to you a
big sign that a return to some level of
normalcy is nearing
came yesterday with a small step from
the centers for disease control they're
easing their recommendations
to say fully vaccinated people can
travel within the u.s
without being tested or going into
quarantine
even before friday's announcement travel
in the u.s has been taking off
the tsa reports 22 straight days of more
than one million u.s
flyers americans domestic bookings are
at 90 percent of pre-pandemic levels
and starting may 1st delta will no
longer block
middle seats we know that travel was up
from the month of march
more so than it had been since the
beginning of this pandemic we know that
right now we have a
surging number of cases the cdc's travel
guidelines issued friday
remained cautious and limited targeting
only the 17 percent of the population
now
fully vaccinated if you are vaccinated
it is lower at risk
for most of the country the risks of
getting infected are still high
and this week experts began sounding the
alarm
of a possible fourth wave there's a 10
percent
case increase in 24 states with michigan
hit hardest
daily cases are up five-fold since the
end of february
too many americans are acting as if this
fight is over it is not
i plead with you don't give back the
progress
we've also fought so hard to achieve
the biggest spike in kids as infection
rates jumped 230 percent among those
under 10 years old
doctors link youth sports and social
events to the increase
but pfizer thinks its vaccine which the
company says is safe for children as
young as 12
will help pfizer is expected to ask the
fda for emergency use
authorization soon potentially promising
for even younger children
too there are studies underway in
children
that go from six months to 11 years
and by the end of this year we should
have enough information
to be able to safely vaccinate children
virtually any age and another sign that
we're moving in the right direction the
curtain went up in music venues and
comedy clubs here in new york city last
night for the first time
in more than a year and cbs cameras were
there
when jerry seinfeld dropped by the
gotham comedy club
to do a surprise set dana yeah tom i saw
some of that that was absolutely amazing
not in person but saw that he was there
we appreciate it thank you